all right let's wrap up where we started
today at blue road earth wants to know
do you know of contingency plans being
made by the nfl to play in the fall i
can't see how it can be business even
close to as usual five months from now
we talked about this when we went on the
air at 7am eastern chris the nonchalance
that i detected from jeff pasch the
nfl's general counsel saying our plan is
to go forward with a full season
full stadiums 16 games start on time
i i i just hope that is some kind of
strange bravado and that behind that
they really are churning and working and
and and generating ideas for how to get
the most uh out of a bad situation if we
do get to the point where this
coronavirus pandemic requires the nfl to
truncate the season i just think it is
way too optimistic at this point to plan
for a full football season
yeah i'm with you mike and i don't hear
any rumors of any contingency plans and
that's the thing i brought up during the
show that scares me a little bit you
know there's just no talk of that we're
hearing rumors about you know major
league baseball nba basketball hockey
trying to figure out ways to finish
their season and make things right that
way we haven't heard one inkling and
i've talked to a lot of coaches while
i'm sitting my butt here at home during
this this lockdown and i'm just telling
you none of them have heard anything
either and they are very skeptical that
this season will be normal i think most
coaches look at it right now and just go
there's no way how how can we play a
full slate of uh you know a full slate
of scheduled games and everything like
that it doesn't look good right now yeah
i think that i would prefer the nfl to
say we're planning not just for a season
we're planning for everything and we'll
be ready for whatever the public health
situation dictates at the time we're
optimistic that we will be in a spot
where we can play in full stadiums by
then but if we can't we will have a plan
i think that's what's more comforting to
people not this kind of stubborn we
intend to go forward because people are
going to look at that and say are you
not paying attention to what's happening
in the world and i think the more
comforting thing is don't worry we will
have a plan no matter what happens we
will have a plan we're identifying all
of our options and we will bring you
football in 2020. i think that would go
a lot farther to make people think the
nfl number one
uh gets it and number two
really is connected to reality when it
comes to coming up with a plan for 2020.
yeah well i you know it bothers me and
that's where you know i get into the
conversation again where you know the
commissioner for our sport works for the
32 owners and he's not necessarily
always seem to be worried about
everybody else it's more about just
pleasing them you know and i look at
yeah my neighbor who lives down the
street here adam silver you know i just
think he's shown great leadership
throughout this you know let alone just
easing the public easing the players of
his league there's constant conversation
and rumors about alternate plans and
what they might do and i think as an nfl
football fan and a guy who loves the nfl
and i got great respect for roger
goodell i just don't hear enough of that
and that bothers me a little bit
well and just think of it this way and
i'm not trying to make it political look
how long it took the experts who are
providing advice to the president to
finally break down that wall to get him
to understand this is serious and all
accounts coming out of yesterday's
briefing from the white house is that
the the president was as concerned and
as as pessimistic as he's ever been
um
finally because they they put the
paperwork on his desk that got his
attention about how serious it's gonna
be and and i think maybe in time
assuming that there are experts around
the commissioner they can get the
commissioner to understand that this
this you know that group dynamic of
everything is going to be fine if you
have enough people in the room saying
everything is going to be fine they're
all going to believe everything is going
to be fine even if it's not that's my
concern that it's just this echo chamber
where they've got themselves convinced
it's going to be fine and then at some
day they're going to open the door and
they're going to say holy crap it's not
fine that and then they're not going to
have enough time to come up with a good
plan that's why i'm saying now take it
seriously and come up with the plans
because if you wait until after the
draft if you wait until june or july
not
to come up with the best plan and you're
gonna have to pull the plug on the seas
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports